what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are jumping back into Batman
the white knight we're on issue number
seven we're almost done we have like
this one and then one like the
conclusion and and God do this story is
so god this story is is it's crazy how
good this whole thing yes alright so
basically what we have here light like
we pick up with this whole thing with
like the Joker quote-unquote returning
and that's kind of the cool thing here
is in all honesty I love the idea of
Jack Napier I love the idea of like the
Joker going sane but at the end of the
day it is the Joker I like the Joker as
the crazy guy everybody likes the Joker
as the crazy guy and that's really what
Shaun Murphy gives us to a degree and
it's cool the way he puts this sort of
twist on the way he puts this kind of
caveat on it is what we end up finding
out is that with the Joker personality
kicking back in what's happening is that
meds are losing their effect basically
his body's becoming immune to it and the
result is that the Joker personality is
constantly pushing itself out and it's
cool because it gives us this kind of
internal battle between like Jack Napier
and the Joker himself which is something
that I love to see with regards to like
how this story's unfolding but from here
we switch over to Batman and again this
is kind of cool because Batman is of
course locked up in Arkham Asylum and
the one thing that I've been seeing in
the comments this is why I love the way
Shaun Murphy writes this the one thing
I've been seeing in the comments really
more than anything else is no way Batman
would be locked up in Arkham Asylum he
knows a million ways to get out this is
one of the things that I want you guys
to notice about Batman and hopefully
it's one of the things that you guys
have picked up on as we've gone through
this story Batman as he's depicted here
in this particular story is kind of
primitive I mean it's not like he's like
stupid or anything like that but like
when you compare the way like this
Batman dresses or like the quality of
the Batcave or the vehicle he drives to
like the DC rebirth Batman they almost
seem like night and day
this guy is wearing what amounts to like
weightlifting gloves and he's got like a
Batman uniform on but it doesn't quite
have the same kind of pizzazz right like
the same kind of shiny polished you know
I'm Batman and I'm so technologically
advanced and I'm like a man from the
future you don't see those kind of
things in this this is a far more
grounded far more tangible and far more
real Batman and it works it works so
well because this is the kind of Batman
you would expect to see what makes
Batman unique and the reason why he kind
of stands the test of time regardless of
like what his uniform is is the
intelligence and the martial arts skill
of Batman his ability to like deduce
things that people wouldn't normally be
able to pick up combined with his
ability to just be the crap out of
people that's what makes Batman timeless
you know sort of Shaun Murphy putting
his own twist on how Batman
while simultaneously giving us the
character that we all know and love and
so from here it picks up with Jack
Napier going to meet neo Joker because
remember she's basically kind of like
taken over the city of Gotham right I
mean usually like this massive freeze
cannon that was developed by the father
of Victor freeze what she's done is
basically just like frozen over the city
of Gotham but with regards to neo Joker
she's like the new Harley Quinn that was
the whole basis of the story the
original Harley Quinn left without Jack
Napier Joker ever realizing it the new
Harley Quinn took his place and then
when the old one came back the new
Harley took off and became neo Joker she
became the new version of the Joker but
her idea has always been I want Joker
back it's cool because in a lot of ways
neo Joker kind of represents the fan
base this is the reader we sit down we
start reading Batman the white knight
because we see the solicitations all
over the place in DC rebirth and we're
like wow that looks cool and then we
start cracking it open we start just
tearing through the pages and we're like
oh my god this is one of the greatest
Batman stories ever written but then
like we start to see Joker go sing and
at the end of the day it's like that's
cool but like I want to see the Joker
I want the Joker back it's so neo
Joker's kind of a stand-in for us but
like we want to see the Joker return in
some form or fashion
Jack Napier's idea is fine if you want
the Joker back then we'll bring the
Joker back and he lets that part of his
personality kind of break loose for a
moment when he suddenly says like the
Joker will return on my terms and so
that's kind of a cool thing notice this
Jack Napier begins to kind of use the
Joker as a weapon it's his own gun his
his switchblade his pocket knife it's a
weapon for him to use to achieve a
certain goal now the other thing to bear
in mind here is he doesn't have total
control in this instance he sort of just
you know opens the door unless the Joker
come out and then shuts the door again
it's like dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde it's
like Bruce Banner in the Incredible Hulk
just because the Joker's there and Jack
Napier let him out does it mean that
Jack Napier has control over the Joker
and that's why this is awesome is
because we kind of get the best of both
worlds for the shorts for a short span
of time the other thing to bear in mind
here is the original Harley Quinn
Harley's torn up about this like Jack
maybe you're going saying Jack maybe are
becoming a regular guy was the greatest
thing that could happen to him because
in the mind of Harley Quinn he can
finally do what Batman's never been able
to do every day Batman is one step
forward one step back he's a dog chasing
his tail he's going nowhere but with
Jack Napier it was legitimately
changing Gotham City effecting change in
a way that could tangibly be seen and
tangibly be felt that's what made him so
successful is he won the hearts and
minds of people but that's the
interesting thing here is because when
you look at this
you Asian you say yeah sure he clean up
Gotham because none of the villains are
there but none of the villains are there
because they're all under the control of
neo Joker and that's the question that
Shaun Murphy asked did he really save
Gotham City or does it just look that
way because the circumstances are
unfolding themselves in a way that keeps
the villains at bay while everything
seems to be going back to normal
not only that Batman had basically
figured out that because Harley Quinn
was the one who was working so hard to
try to keep Jack maybe Jack Napier sane
at the end of the day Batman has figured
out that like Harley Quinn will push
Jack Napier in the direction of seeking
out the help of Batman because there's
no other option that he has it's the
only choice he has here The Joker needs
Batman and in a lot of ways neo Joker
was right when she said the Joker is
going to come back and make his return
because his ego won't let neo Joker
conquer Gotham but Gotham is is is a
half-measure it's incomplete if Batman's
not there and so with Jack Napier
showing up and suddenly saying like if I
let the Joker out if I let him run amok
sure he'll take out neo Joker and he'll
conquer Gotham as well because you're
not out there you're not out there
stopping here made out there chasing him
and so Jack maybe or grabs Batman brings
him along and says you've got to save me
here but this is kind of a cool moment
because the two of them sort of get into
this argument like Jack maybe or in
Batman sort of argue with one another
over who it is is actually doing any
good
Jack De Beers argument is I've made
Gotham a better place in ways that
you've never been able to do and your
entire career as Batman and while I
can't necessarily stop all those
villains what I've done is I've managed
to get the people to care about the city
that they live in they don't live in
fear anymore they live in in confidence
but they can walk down the street and
keep their city safe from everybody else
they're not relying on you and you've
never been able to effect that change
you've never been able to inspire people
but Batman's argument is yeah but you
broke the law to do it and the jack
neighbor comes back with this perfect
argument and says yeah but so did you
you're a vigilante you operated outside
of the law you weren't held accountable
to anybody I got to the support of the
public I work with the police I don't
work alongside them as someone who's
just there it's an awesome argument
because that's 100% true I think in
years to come people will look at this
and see it as like a critique of Batman
that's what it is it's a critique of the
Batman character he operates outside of
the law he does what he wants when he
wants how he wants and it just happens
to be that he works in the in the
interests of Gotham City Batman says
like my allegiance is to Gotham but at
no point has he sought to help with the
people and no point has he has he
inspired the people to do something
better he's always suddenly just taken
the weight of the city on his shoulders
and said it's my job now to protect
everyone
whereas Jack Napier took the people to
the fight said look I am here like you
I'm not someone above the city itself I
am a citizen I do all the things that
I'm supposed to I want to be a part of
this rule of this army of Gotham I don't
want to lead this army of Gotham and
that's why it's so awesome and that's
why it works so well now ultimately
because of the fact that like the
overarching goal is to take out neo
Joker the two of them end up hearing up
the jack navier's argument is look when
that man says I want a full confession
from you for everything that you've done
since you've been Jack Napier all the
criminal activity that you've been
involved in because he has been involved
in some pretty seedy stuff he has broken
the law he says I want a full confession
jack neighbor says fine I'll give you
your confession but Harley Quinn has to
go free you cannot have Harley Quinn
intertwine in this she does not get
arrested for anything and this is cool
because this is like the one unifying
factor that Joker and Jack Napier share
Harley Quinn Harley Quinn well while we
may say that like Batman is the center
of Joker's world to a degree that's true
but the fact that like Harley the
original holiday Quinn took off and like
Joker sought out a new one means Joker
always needs a Harley Quinn she's an
intrinsic part of his life with Jack
Napier it's the same way he always has
her by his side she's as closest
confidant so of course with the two of
them teaming up what we end up having is
Batman asking the question saying if we
work together there's one thing that I
want to know I want to know what
happened to Jason Todd because remember
Shawn Murphy kind of flipped the script
on us with this one what we ended up
finding out here is Jason Todd was Robin
before Dick Grayson and main DC
continuity Dick Grayson was Robin long
before Jason Todd Jason Todd was the
second Robin Tim Drake was the third and
then Damian Wayne was the fourth and so
all we really knew was that the whole
situation involving Jason Todd went down
almost identical to like death in the
family and that was awesome because that
story is so landmark in the Batman
mythos but it was basically the idea
that like Joker had killed Jason Todd
what we end up having is this revelation
coming from from Jack Napier that like
Jason Todd's not dead we end up finding
out that like the one thing that Joker
wanted was to know the identity of
Batman not so he could take him out by
knowing the identity of Batman Joker
would know something that Batman didn't
and so Joker would have something on him
he'd have a measure of control over
Batman if all else fails it'd be the one
thing Joker knows that Batman doesn't
isn't aware of the Joker knows and so
when Jason Todd just kind of snapped you
know when when when he basically offered
his last words and said I wish I never
met Bruce Wayne Joker cuts him loose
because he's finally revealed the
identity but that's where
Jack maybe kinda makes his revelation
Jaison Todd's alive he's not dead he's
free-floating out there in the world
somewhere who knows maybe he'll come
back as Red Hood
we have no earthly clue but he wants you
to believe he's dead because he felt
like you betrayed him that you took him
under under your wing to become Robin we
don't really know that backstory we can
largely surmise that it happened the
same way it did in the post-crisis
landscape you basically Jason Todd was a
guy who boosted you know almost who
stole the wheels off the Batmobile
basically but like we can assume that
happened but we don't know for sure all
we know is that Jason Todd became Robin
somewhere along the line and the result
was that with the two of them largely
fought as a dynamic duo that when when
Jason Todd was brought into the world of
Batman he was brought into a world of
danger and death and so when Jay $0.20
Todd was taken by the Joker was having
the absolute Harvie out of him and on
the edge of dying
the one thing he resented above all
others was being brought in by Bruce
Wayne was being adopted by Bruce Wayne
he wishes he'd never met the man and so
that seems to instill this massive
hatred for Batman on behalf of Jason
Todd and it's cool because it works
because what this does is it sets things
up for like the introduction of the Red
Hood it's Shawn Murphy you know if this
story really became as huge as is as it
seems to be if it really is one of these
things were like it turns into a story
that Shawn Murphy can build off of then
we can see Red Hood introduced the
foundation is already there but again
with the two of them kind of sliding it
kind of working together Batman has to
put out a little bit of pass behind him
he has to kind of walk away from that
whole situation and focus almost
strictly on the here and now and so
going to visit Victor freeze and asking
the question of how it is if Victor
freeze is going to help with this whole
situation Victor says the same thing
that he told Barbara Gordon there's
nothing I can do here I don't know how
this machine works construction on this
massive weapon started after I'd already
left my father when I took off and I
came to the United States I don't know
the ins and outs of it but what he does
do is he offers us information on how to
like access the island of where the
machines at without you know neo Joker
knowing what he basically says is like
when the machine was being constructed
because Batman asked how could how could
this thing have been built with no one
knowing about it and Victor fre says
they were using tunnels you know
literally Thomas Wayne had tunnels
constructed under Gotham City that
basically all reached to this one
specific location they brought in all
kinds of things to see this thing
constructed underground so nobody would
be aware of it and that's what's awesome
is because it's one of these things like
Commissioner Gordon kind of says it
himself you never learn everything about
Gotham City there's always something new
to learn but again this is Shawn Murphy
kind of turning the table flipping the
script on a lot of things and saying
Thomas Wayne Amarth Wayne we're
the kindly people who were just in the
wrong place at the wrong time or just
shot in cold blood by Joe Chill they
have a dark history and so ultimately
they end up basically outlining
themselves you know kind of coming
together The Joker banding alongside
Batman who's working alongside the bat
family who's working alongside the
Gotham police department this entire
group basically led by Batman and the
Joker they end up like making their wage
where is the island where neo Joker is
currently residing and the idea is that
man Sibley says like okay this is your
shot jack like this is your shot to get
out there get into the head of neo Joker
and basically serve as a distraction
we have no idea what'll happen to him
but like your job is to get in there to
be a distraction and get into her head
while we can in there and basically take
everything down to bring this entire
empire crumbling down around her after
which we have no clue what happens we
have to wait for the next issue but we
have being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explained make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the Rob port if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]